[Music]
35 year old
russian influencer that got
famous for her weight loss surgery oh
that was boris
has recently gained it all back
no like there's some controversy
oh like she did actually lose it like
she like just got it cut off it actually
has nothing to do with her weight loss
she said she got surgery what did you
say she got surgery or just weight loss
not just her weight loss journey but it
has nothing that was just the reason why
she's
popular she's just saying like this is
why she's like some famous influencer
person
that's her claim to fame is that but
there's this whole controversy
going on around her because
she has divorced her 45 year old husband
who she had been married to for 10 years
and they
shared five like they adopted five um
cats no five kids and uh they
then he had two boys from a previous
marriage and now collector huh
yeah got seven kids seven kids i mean he
must be rich though let me guess
she doesn't wanna take care of them oh
no i mean she
really wants to take care of one ew
he must be hot having a relationship
with the step with the steps on
oh that's like a porno with her 20 year
old
stepson that's like a dream oh
oh no oh my god
this the lady raised that little dude
and that little dude grew up
and now they're freaking what big
you know it's interesting that she looks
younger
when she's older and she looks she lost
a lot of weight so so when you're fatter
you look older this is her
transformation
like the her raises the same dusty you
know what's really disgusting is she's
an influencer
that is disgusting no i mean like um
she kind of sucks what are you talking
about
she just because she's an influencer no
no no like like
this is the caliber of an influencer i
expect more she sucks
yeah she doesn't she sucks as a person
that's true she sucks at everything she
sucks at
mommy marriage damn she's better here
pretty attractive
to her she might be the best mom 400 000
followers
yeah damn she looks like a cute couple
she's got a big following
i want to know in the comments because
you know sometimes there's oh it's never
one-sided
i want to see who's on her side i like
that dog i don't know man
i thought there's people a bunch of
people the people that are on her side
is like well [ __ ] it they're two
consenting grown adults
they can do whatever they want no like
they're not blowing you know she cooks
good and takes care of them really good
what if we're just judging with our
judgy american values i'm gonna judge
with my own american values because if
i'm raising
a person as my child yeah even though
we're not blood related they're forever
my child
that's outside of that too like we're
thinking of the red flags of like
does she condition that's exactly what a
lot of people are that's what you're
thinking that's what i'm thinking i was
thinking
maybe in the rush in the russian ways
they're like
you're always half romantic half not
is it
interesting just from the start you know
does the conditioning you know the
direction the better than i do how do
you think the relationship between
the son and the dad is now i know they
must be best pals you're like bro you
stole my wife
they're eskimo brothers yeah what is
that
the igloo he's a true [ __ ] is
what i'm thinking i never heard that one
really
she's the igloo eskimo brothers yeah
eskimo brothers is you share the same
lady never heard that because he's like
daddy don't call me daddy we are not
brothers
brothers
yeah so now because of this relationship
um well so they have made an
announcement
that they're they're planning to get
married
and because of this relationship coming
to light the
child services they have now taken away
all the other kids her adopted children
and placed them with her ex-husband but
she's like they're all ugly though he
was the cutest one
he's the one i wanted oh god what a
nasty situation
are they about to have kids please no
please no i think they want to well
they're not blood related right they're
not but it's
what do you think do you think i say you
adopted a bunch of kids right and then
you started dating one and then
child services took away all the other
ones do you think that's fair
of course okay well i mean wait but i'm
the one dating
my own kid no no you're the the the son
of your husband
well yeah in this situation but they're
actually three of them are hers
right no they're adopted oh they're
adopted any biological children that i
know of thank god
five of them are adopted with her
ex-husband and then he had
two two boys from a previous marriage
which this kid that she's yeah maybe she
can't have kids that's why they adopted
maybe so he could cream pie on here all
day
what does that have to do with it no
because then uh i think you asked if
they're gonna have kids
no no do you think that's what would you
like is that weird to you
what's weird taking away the kids yeah
because i think they're thinking about
the same lens we're thinking about where
it's like is she conditioning them like
she's conditioning him
i was just thinking like she's probably
like hell yeah i don't gotta take care
of these [ __ ] and me and my
my new son boyfriend can start a new
life
maybe they're like we don't want these
kids two boyfriends called
their brother also their dad yeah that's
weird
which word you use whenever you feel
like one of the others like oh my
my new uncle dad yeah
once if he was the youngest and he
starts disciplining the other kids now
his teammates are dead bro damn so he
has to do
mother's day and valentine's day
for her for the same person i know dude
that's weird wait don't you do that
true true yeah but you don't celebrate
like your own
you're like the mother's day of my child
like you're not mother's day
thank you for raising me yeah happy
mother's day that's the caption he's ra
he's literally saying thank you for
raising me and [ __ ] me
thank you for raising me and giving me
[ __ ] do you think they uh
they ignore the fact that they're mother
and son or do you think they play
like play into it oh i hope they don't
play i bet they play into it i bet they
play into it yeah
and then and then when they think about
memories that are like mother and
daughter i mean like mother and son it's
like remember the time when you took me
to the park and you're like
i cried when i went down the slide and
[ __ ] and then they turned it romantic
no we could [ __ ] uh i want to know
when they started that stuff
very true that's a really vital question
for conditioning yeah yeah yeah what if
he conditioned her
though i know he might have been the
pervert yeah
one mine's much more malleable i don't
know it's the ladies mind probably
true i don't know i was quite the jail
bait but i failed because i wasn't a
good looking kid
i always try to would you do joe if you
had a really hot step mom
it's a stepmom right how desperate am i
this guy do i think she's hot yes and
then like what if this
i mean i don't know like this photo that
she posted to me
she posted it herself she posted this
she's proud of it look i'm a man of
honor
and if i like my dad i'd be like
mom's hot but that's all you dog
no people were commenting saying like oh
my gosh she traded in her husband for a
newer model
that's weird because get this get this
get this cause like sometimes all right
you know like the stereotypical rich dad
right
so like he's like [ __ ] going through
a mid-life crisis he divorces the mom
and he gets with a girl that's younger
than you
and hotter than anybody you've ever seen
so i'm pretty sure there's always
situations like that where they see like
this hot ass
new girlfriend that your dad gets with
and you're like
um [ __ ] your son yup
what do you do there i'm not even
talking about porno i'm talking about
stereotypes that [ __ ] happens
thank god i'm not rich yeah why was she
fell in love with the husband right
and like he was amazing to her and then
something happened where he went bad
yeah but he still saw the old husband
and the kid and the kid oh that's what
happened he's abusive we don't know
maybe the dad's
a piece of [ __ ] maybe that's what
happened there's two sides
oh yeah and he's like you remind me of
your dad when i met him when he was
younger
no oh i want to vomit i don't i don't
give a [ __ ] if there's two sides
you can't do that with taika what this
reminds you of me a lot
right now looks like you copy and paste
gio's face inside
it's just his head is his head shape
that's disgusting what compels a person
to do some [ __ ] like this
okay like because i can't think of a
in a female's perspective right but to
me it's like
you hear these stories of like lady
teachers
that bang their students and all guys
are kind of like low-key thinking
i wish that was me she's so hot but then
in this case i don't feel that way
because she's [ __ ] ugly
you look at those new mom
she said this is a mom it's not even
it's not even a teacher
right but what kind of mind takes a a
mom
to want to [ __ ] her kid that's the
weirdest [ __ ]
it's crazy because for us it's even this
like just us talking about it
it would be a whole different story if
it was the dad doing that to
her daughter do you know what i mean
yeah
well he would have gone to jail we just
talked about the director
yeah woody allen we just talked about
woody allen is that what he did
a chinese girl or something and now
they're married and they've been
together
for however many years and he divorced
his wife
so is that true love because i mean they
didn't break up that's kind of got what
got him canceled right
yeah i mean thank god he's still making
stuff is he making stuff
after that he still did but it didn't go
anywhere but don't they say all
is fair and love and war so is it okay
to do whatever it takes to find your
true love even if it's banging your mom
it makes me feel weird or banging your
daughter or your son or your father
it's disgusting there's so many people
you know that saying there's so many
fish in the sea
yeah there's a it's a [ __ ] wide and
vast sea go find another fish you
[ __ ]
but whatever what if they're like what
if they look at
uh you're an eagle you're so basic
you don't love their family the way i do
maybe that person's like
the grass is always greener i got my
green grass right here baby
wines are just so like minimalistic and
like simple
i don't have to do [ __ ] yeah they don't
want to why why would i have my
mother and my lover and two different
people if i could put them i want to
organize them together
consolidate my family keep it for the
whole valentine's day mother's day thing
they're just like let's just make that
one holiday yeah so much efficiency
gross
there's times mother's time they're
really just very minimalistic
it's also green for the earth i think if
you spend enough time with someone
they're no longer sexualized and i think
that's what's so weird
or maybe that's the challenge you gotta
spend enough time and still try a
section he goes we have true love
because we spent all our lives together
we still horny for each other
and then they're like you wish you was
jealous oh
i bet you can't kiss your mom like this
because you know how we had that
question a while ago it was like okay
imagine if you had like a long-lost
sibling and you never [ __ ] met them
but they're hot as hell yeah and you get
together right
like that jon snow question or it's like
you grew up with a step sibling but
you're maybe you're not even blood
related maybe they're adopted but you've
been with them all your life right
and some people were like yeah i'd
rather be with the step sibling because
we're not together together and other
people were like
nah i'd [ __ ] my biological sister that
i'd never met
[ __ ] i don't know can i just kill myself
oh we have one or the other
we have to pick one or the other we had
this question in a while you have to i
said
i said i would rather [ __ ] my biological
sister that i never
no you know why they probably look good
because they look like me
and there's no history there's no
history that makes more sense it makes
way more sense
psychologically yeah psychological like
if you grew up no
it's not though i i agree because of the
no biological
i mean because of the no history but if
you decide to be in love and start a
family
that is already like i'm talking about
like john's not like jon
make there be less orphans in the world
see then you're doing good i'm talking
about what if you had a passionate time
with them and afterwards you find out
and you're like
oh [ __ ] yeah what would you feel like
say you had sex with both
no when you were well you gotta [ __ ] two
sisters to figure out what you want
no no say you [ __ ] uh her right and then
you're like and then you find out that
she was actually your real sister right
yeah
or so okay so you already did it you did
it and then now thinking about it and
then you're like oh my god that's crazy
right
and then someone came along was like
would you rather have done that or [ __ ]
your
fake step sister now knowing that she is
i mean you grew up with her
i think the stepsister is worse
even though in porno today that's more
acceptable yeah
but i'd rather do a to me it's like
biologically yeah but we were separated
we're com i don't we're complete
strangers
oh god what about say okay say you're
18 or 17 right the cat fell asleep and
then you know
and then your dad married another person
and they had a daughter on the same age
and you guys just met is that bad
because you guys are just now became
step sisters my brothers
yeah there's so many technicalities
teaching us your movie right now huh
did you guys see a movie right now movie
ideas you know what they say
incest wincest
you